[Music]
please don't get involved
what is up thick fam it is monday august
1st what's poppin daddy how you guys
doing everything good you guys doing all
right out there that's cool
um not much going on here man coming
fresh
off the press you got a cowbest fight
campaign for ufc 277. we had eric
griffin on crystalia and my boy matt
matrion poor matt flight was delayed got
here late
and then was flying out the next one at
6 a.m so shout out to matt matrion for
getting it done and
you know just being the overall good guy
that he is and i thought eric griffin
being the new guy in the fight campaign
listen
we do fight companies they're three
hours long uh even high level comics
after about an hour and a half two hours
they kind of die out eric griffin was a
fantastic addition eric i thought was
great man eric was really good so if you
haven't seen it it's up right now it's
available on the thick boy youtube only
we shoot it live but then it uploads
right after um i think you guys did it's
a fun one it's a really fun one
with the boys watching ufc 277 me and
matt were the only ones drinking
we have two big fight companions in
august um
the contracts we i just got i'll sh i i
should be able to announce it uh this
week and that will probably happen on
finance kid or we'll do like
a breaking announcement on uh my
social media or thick boy social media
but we have some big announcements
coming up in regards to fight companion
what's next for us in august but
hopefully we get that rolling soon for
you guys so we can announce it start
promoting it be fun man we all have
stuff in the works
um i'll tell you what uh everyone knows
sunday's uh malibu carson coffee with
the kiddos i wake up and there's nothing
more that my two-year-old son boston
loves more
here's what's interesting and i'm going
to post about this and complain as well
they decide to shut it down they shut
down the cars and coffee
they shut it down and they um
i the business was crying because uh
they said you know it was affecting
their business which didn't make sense
to me because it was always packed
and they're like if they were just left
there like they used to at seven a.m
we'd be fine but they pushed it back so
that used to be 10 used to be 11.
if you think about it
you know i'm like i don't mind early i'm
up at six anyways with the kiddos so
early for me works
when you think about people that have
cars i would assume
generally you know older right dudes so
it makes sense to to do it earlier
because old guys have nothing to do
right especially their kids if it's a
empty nest situation you know they're
just
whatever driving their ferraris or some
of those [ __ ] corvettes and they're
driving to malibu right but uh it became
a younger thing so younger audience like
why are we waking up at seven so you
start pushing back 10 11
i assume that affected business even
though it was crowded there people were
just there for the car so
they're being coffee and like snacks but
they weren't buying like merchandise so
the businesses they're all i guess voted
or i don't know how to protest some [ __ ]
but
nobody told me there was there's been
rumblings of this for years like if you
listen to spike as a podcast he's jerry
seinfeld's best friend they own car they
have like a car club together spike um
they've talked about it before but
it's been a rumor for like years years
since i started going it's like oh this
thing could shut down any time
nothing ever so i didn't think thing of
it show up sunday my two-year-old was
like dad where are all the cars that it
was packed but it was like
tiger was like that was so many [ __ ]
priuses and tesla's like
so uh i think they relocated if you did
relocate let me know
let me know that would be fantastic
because my kids are brokenhearted
hey business owners be cool man you
ruined it for the families you know be
[ __ ] cool so we'll see hopefully they
bring that back but um
yeah man uh heavy heart today my grandpa
passed away this morning 6 am passed
away she was 99 though you know so it's
what old people do
you know it's a bummer though either way
when they go it's one of my pops my pops
is really close to her so i'm gonna deal
with that
so we'll see how that goes but um
yeah man let's get right into the fights
you had a big ufc 277 pay-per-view
headlined by amanda nunes and julia pena
co-main event was brian moreno in
kaicara france
um and then the main card was good also
the the undercard was you know solid uh
definitely the all-star of the undercard
was drew dober if you remember last week
i highlighted this fight drew dober
versus hafiel alves fantastic fight
these boys were the
best fight in the card let's be honest
as far as action-packed you know and um
rafael alva's is no punk and drew dober
um just a savage with it savage with
ties to colorado trains out of colorado
um but he might be a few executives from
b trains of xfc out there but drew dober
with a you know
great fight a best fight in the card i
thought he's a savage uh yep fighting
out different colorado holler uh via
omaha nebraska i didn't want to say
nebraska because i was thinking of
anthony smith but yeah he is out of
nebraska but he was on the scene when i
was fighting he's always been like a
local superstar in denver so he's
fighting getting his due now after that
last fight man that was a great shot to
the body so he'd be my mvp of the
prelims but um you know for the main
card
overall it is it's pretty good you know
you got uh uh magamed uh vs anthony
smith that one's a bummer and anthony
smith was supposed to be on food truck
this week but we postponed we're gonna
do it in two weeks um but anthony smith
compromised his ankle original reports
was he broke his ankle but apparently he
didn't break it he didn't break it
what's he say here avoids broken bones
we're not sure exactly what what
happened though yet what's weird about
the a so no fracture white said when i
dressed himself injury um
so it was unfortunate ending for smith
as he sought to earn a tough shot with
the wind out appears even without a
broken leg that needs some time off
healing yep so
you know i thought he's doing pretty
well in that first round it was a tough
for fight for him either way um i did
put money on him i thought he was too
big of a dog and i thought he
experienced mugger mad is is no [ __ ]
punk and
for him the title shots
is not next for him uh
you know the the next tosh i would be
yuri versus glover yuri and glover both
want that fight i would imagine the ufc
does it for um
mega med on the same card they should
have uh mega med versus um
uh john blockovich that's what i think
would be next for him
and again i think the jury's still out
on mugging med you know he's a [ __ ]
savage but
um
we don't know that anthony smith won we
i thought that was gonna be a dog fight
for him anthony smith compromised his
ankle so what's weird too about the
ankles
sometimes a break is better than
whatever he did to it sometimes the
break is either get surgery and get it
done because your ankle has this weird
memory so when you spring it really bad
you're out way longer than if you just
broke the [ __ ] thing off so
um hopefully anthony smith is all right
man but i thought that was going to be a
good test for mega bad didn't know where
he was at i still don't know listen he's
a savage he's got he's
making but 205 pounds you know so
um i would assume a guy like yon is an
experiment
title shots not happening you know him
versus yuri you could do it i wouldn't
be mad at it but i would assume they
give him a guy like uh john buckovich
which is a great test for him let's see
how he does against yon and then he's
going sizzler you know but again i tell
you guys this all the time it's just a
matter of time before every champions
from dagestan or [ __ ] russia that's
all that's happening here so just
delaying the inevitable you know what
i'm saying um
the
exciting is [ __ ] fight on flyweight
alexander uh pantoja versus alex perez i
told you guys this last week
i was worried about alex perez because
he's been inactive
and his last
fight was what two years ago to the
champ
and uh you know he lost that fight
you're not active they put you on a big
main card of a pay-per-view then they
give you alexander pantoja and you know
he knows being on this
in the co-main event is the title fight
in your division he wanted to show out
and my god did he show out he looked
[ __ ] fantastic i would assume he is
the he he gets the loser of bran moreno
kaiker of france obviously brian
moreno's going to fight figorito again
for the rubber match which i can't wait
for
um also his entrance when brian moreno
won in the middle of speech was awkward
whatever um but i would assume pen
pentosia gets kai care france
that's the way this thing goes uh sir
sergey pavalo pavlovic versus derek
lewis
dude poor derrick lewis right texas just
isn't his cup of tea there's too much
pressure on him in there i thought you
know uh tough fight for him
if it was outside of texas i would
definitely put money on derrick lewis i
didn't put money on dirk list for this
fight
um you know dick lewis although he's a
knockout artist and you know he's one of
the best knockouts of all time in the
heavyweight division or for the ufc for
that matter
you know the
the jury's out on the verdict's out you
know he has these big looping punches
straight down the pipe and being
technical beats him that's what sergey
did a lot of people have issues with the
stoppage i don't know what dana said in
the post fight press conference but
anytime in the heavyweight division when
a guy's getting hit if he falls face
first and doesn't put his hands out to
stop him i'm gonna [ __ ] how quick he
gets back to his feet as a ref i think
it was dan mergulotta
you gotta stop it
they're heavyweights you have to stop it
so i don't have an issue with it um you
know derek was kind of getting beat up
in that
yeah i know he popped up and he's upset
so the fans are upset and derek lewis is
way more famous and way more of a fan
favorite so i think that's where the
outcry comes but sergey was gonna win
that fight man
that's tough
um
moreno kai care of france they fought
before
actually you know i think the judges had
it 1-1 going to that third round i
actually thought kaiker france found his
timing in that third round
moreno was losing that third round um
you know and his face would show that
you know he looked pretty beat up in the
post fight press conference um but then
you know body kick there's nothing you
can do you can be the toughest guy in
the world you get hit to the body in the
right spot there's nothing you do you
know especially if it's good timing
especially you know
you're holding your breath or you just
hit you in the perfect spot i don't care
how tough you are there's no amount of
toughness that can
you know stop a a hard hit to the body
liver shot stomach shot solar plex shot
from
putting you down it just doesn't it
doesn't so
moreno does the goddamn thing
my mexican household was scrunk of [ __ ]
and then you're getting the the trilogy
the rubber match against figarito i
think he beats figarito i root for bram
moreno
dude the nicest guy in the roster hands
down nice guy of all time
co-made event not much of a fight um
they had it 50 45 50 44 50 43 i was more
on the board of 50 43 even 50 42 to be
honest
um
you know if you watch the first fight
which i went back and watched it last
week before the pay-per-view
you know you you have to ask yourself is
julian a penny is it just her time which
i kind of thought it was and because
that first fight amanda nunes
you know she's been known for a while
she's great to ever do it she has money
she's a kid she's married she's going
through the motions where on the street
she wasn't training that hard she just
seemed over it and julian pena was
foaming at the mouth to become a world
champion and it showed in that first
fight so
going in the second fight it was all
predicated there's a reason why she was
a dog it was all predicated on
how bad does amanda is amanda is just
done she know is she checked out she's
checked out there can be a worse person
fight than julian opinion with her
pressure her tenacity it's gonna be
tough man
but
she she she [ __ ] with the brazilian uh
bullhorns and and she got the bull you
know what i'm saying so amanda is ready
to go she's smiling i thought this could
be a case of man nunes not want to be in
there trying to gear out in the first
round julian pena weathering the first
round and then slowly breaking her down
taking her down eventually submitting in
the third or fourth round my god was i
off this wasn't competitive
the problem with if you're a julian pena
fan which i'm a huge fan i'm actually a
bigger fan of her than other women in
the division but
the problem is if you're juliana pena
fan
i don't know what ground you have to
stand on to ask for a rematch even
though it's one in one
you know if you remember george st
pierre met sarah right matt sarah
clipped them and then finish them off
biggest upset of all time by far i know
people think um julia pena nunez or
holly holm rendez
matt sarah gsp to me is the biggest of
all time for a number of reasons but if
you remember they rematched and george
beat the [ __ ] out of it made it very
clear that he was just overlooking him
at that time george was always training
hard but george was drinking wine after
that fight he stopped drinking wine he
stopped going out stopped hanging out
clubs cut out all alcohol cut out all
social uh
you know
things uh during training camp and got
serious and then beat the [ __ ] out of
matt sarah you know so matt sarah was a
minus eleven hundred
let's take a little break from me just
chatting about fisticuffs baltimore i
will see you this thursday friday
saturday i'm in baltimore magooby's come
get some baltimore
and then after that in august i'll be
doing sets all room la uh laugh factory
improv store i'll be all over la but
then uh baltimore's this week august 4th
through the 6th thursday friday saturday
in baltimore then one night one show
only 7 30 chicago downtown chicago at
the den theater come get some tickets at
thickboy.com
lately i've been listing a lot of
freaking music and podcasts and audio
books and it's been great i do it on my
bike
and a lot of people make fun of me when
i post uh pics or videos when i'm on
bikes you'll see that cords attached to
my earbuds and that's like oh you can't
afford the freaking wireless no i hear
you look at my ears dude i get freaking
tortellini for an air so i have to be
careful they fall out but then
but then some raycon wireless earbuds
came to the crib and i said you know
what i'll give them a shot and they fit
my hair perfectly and they sound
fantastic they are ridiculous raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
all right for the perfect in-air fit
look at these ears they fit these ears
they're going to fit your ears all right
raycon gives you eight hours of play
time and a 32 hour battery life which is
ridiculous raycons are priced just right
you get quality audio at half the price
of other premium audio brands it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 50 000 five-star reviews all right
they're freaking good man i love the
noise isolation especially when i'm on
my bike and also they fit it they're
they fit your boys ears that's the
biggest thing for me man go to buy
raycon dot com shop that's b u y r a y c
o n dot com slash shop s c h a b today
and you get 15 off your raycon order
they are the only earbuds that i use for
my weird ears they're fantastic noise
cancellation they're comfortable i swear
by them go to buy raycon.com
shop for 15 off not sure if you guys are
familiar with this or not but it's going
around all the kids are talking about
it's smooth sack summer that's right if
you haven't heard it is smooth sack
summer when you're playing in the summer
sun make sure you escape from
all over the place man that's right this
summer to keep your balls cool while
still looking hot with manscape the
leader and below the belt grooming is
making sure we all have a ball this
summer by giving our pants partners
everything they need to stay fresh all
summer long dive head first into smooth
sax summer by going to manscape.com for
20 off and free shipping with the code
shob 20 man listen
out there you guys got some bushes
you're shaving your junk and you nip
your nuts that thing bleeds all freaking
day you don't have to worry about that
man manscape helps you with your
confidence down there manscape
performance package 4.0 has everything
you need to prepare that summer bod
inside the package to find a lawnmower
4.0 trimmer a weed whacker ear nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all your
goodies man and listen i've talked about
it before the lawnmower 4.0 if you're
cutting your bush with anything else
you're doing it wrong it's waterproof
has a light on it it's fantastic man we
got you covered get torn off and free
shipping with the code shop20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with code shop20 at
manscape.com it's smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind
so you know
um for for
pena
you know that that was just a complete
beat down it wasn't
you know a competitive fight so it to me
it's just
is there any
fan out there who wants to see the
trilogy match do you chan after saying
that like
if she won like two rounds i could see
it man
besides that first round you could do 10
8
every single i mean it was a really
[ __ ]
outclassed outshine in every aspect
takedowns grappling striking it wasn't
competitive in any facet
1080 across the board except for that
first round
yeah it's a real ass whooping you know
so it's tough for julian payne to go to
ufc go all right what's one in one
there's he's like it is no we know we
know we're good though what we're good
wasn't competitive so i she might have
to get one more and then fight the champ
i don't know how many how much amanda
wants to fight anymore you know
seeing that first right against july
opinion obviously that's there and then
the other thing that was interesting is
you know i can't hear the the broadcast
because so many reasons during fight
campaign but
i figured and i told the camera hey let
me know if a man nunez says all right
we're gonna do is run this back
but she wasn't like foaming at her
brazilian mouth to run it back you know
she was like i'm gonna go home take a
break we'll see because
again i think for her and her legacy it
doesn't do much for to do it a third
time this is so dominant the worst case
scenario for julian opinion worst case
scenario
not competitive uh if if you're her team
you're going back to the drawing board
saying on
what do we got to work on everything you
know how do you beat her i don't know
and a case of a man nunes going south
paul and her check hooked her her
takedowns her timings she looked
phenomenal you know she
vindicated herself as the greatest
female fighter of all time
you know for amanda nunes you know
there's a lot of narrative out there i'd
love to see chef chanko
yeah you know they fought twice right
yeah you know man of news beat her twice
right so that's not going to work now
technically is
shivchenko a better overall
you know
is she more skilled
there's debate there but going off uh
chef chenko's last fight a lot of people
thought she lost that fight so is it
also
if the ufc's gonna do this mega fight
you know i'd say you do it 130 pounds
right not 125 not 135 you do at 130 for
the
uh
b what b m f bad [ __ ] belt still
b beyonce you do that had a catch right
at 130 for both of them they fought
before you know so
um
you know if the ufc does want to do that
super fight between chef chanko and
nunes
you got to do it soon
chef jenga's not getting any younger
uh
you know
amanda nunes also isn't getting younger
so
if if there's one fight left that'd be
the fight i don't think it's a rubber
match with julian opinion i just don't
um and that gash on her head jesus
christ that was bad huh
i heard there was some of her skin like
blood on the [ __ ] cage like inside
the octagon look at that gash dude it
looks pretty bad but she from an elbow
yeah well dana white said it was a chunk
missing out of her head
that she said this
tougher than a two dollar steak well i
tell you what
that girl is tough
here's the thing if i'm here on monday
morning going man that girl is tough it
did not go well the biggest compliment
is that girl's tough that means you got
beat up yeah but you're so goddamn tough
you survived again i said design
companion i think she went gets more
fans now
showing how tough she is yeah after
being champ you see her daughter behind
her at weigh-ins everybody now more
people are familiar with joanna pena and
you see that it wasn't her night she got
beat up but people like toughness people
can relate to toughness i think she
earns more fans now i really do
so she puts tougher than two dollars
steak agree
uh although good luck finding a two
dollar steak these days an inflation
girl even skirt steak is not two dollars
uh tougher than two dollars steak thanks
to everyone just a cat scratch that
required a few stitches no chunk let's
say no surgery necessary love you all
we're one-on-one people's champ trilogy
yep best comment of the day from my boy
mike v
that's kieza yeah what'd he say i'm
guessing the two dollar steak thing uh
yeah tougher than two dollar steak yeah
it's never good when you walk off like
dude you're [ __ ] tough though wait
what look at her daughter that's so cute
so cute
cause i was all breathing heart yeah she
looks like she was serious too like she
was trying to defend her mom yeah so
[ __ ] cute man
so cute
yeah you you for juliana man it's tough
but here's the thing too if you're a
giuliana fan don't be sad amanda doesn't
have a lot of fights left amanda leaves
who's going to be pena
penny is your champ should we champ
again guarantee it garen [ __ ] t-shirt
champ again does she beat around nunes
absolutely not
but a man knew this has one or two
fights left it's probably going to meet
julian opinion it's going to be [ __ ]
shivchenko and then if i'm the ufc i
protect you on opinion i don't see her
get destroyed again because she's going
to be your champ so you do
uh amanda nunes shevchenko in the bmf
fight at 1 30. cash amanda sails off in
the sunset with all her money and her
wife and her kid and then the the
division's open again
who's going to be penny
not many
should be champ
it just sucks to swallow that pill you
know
sucks
what do you got jim um back to nunes
this is what she said about the fight
i know juliana's tough
i know i was ready for that i could have
i could have finished her but i wanted
to go five rounds with her tonight to
prove i was better than her i'm better
than her and i proved it tonight yeah i
think i agree
yeah agree
agree
she's your best female fighter of all
time love to hear a debate i
where was i at
maybe i was in fort wayne this guy came
out because man you always say uh
you always say uh
a man who's the best all the time he
goes the argument is uh cyborg i'm like
well she beat cyborg sir he's like can
we talk about something like take all
the time you want it's meet and greet
i'm like i'm here all night buddy and
he's like well he's like remember though
and this good point he goes remember
uh
um
amanda nunes beat
cyborg when she wasn't in a prime
he got a weathered cyborg it wasn't like
it was prime he was like take prime
cyborg prime
uh a madness who wins like not bad i'm a
bad argument
prime cyborg was a killer fantastic yeah
yeah
yeah
i go based off now that's why that's why
goats and best of all time it's tough
it's all debatable you take him in the
prime it's tough you know
like chuck and tito chuck tito also when
it comes to heavyweight like
people say stipe or you know for doom i
think the big argument for for doom or
you know but in the prime like in the
peak of their height of the career
i've never seen a better heavyweight
than cain velasquez hands down
i don't think anybody beats him fade on
his prime cro cop in his prime brock
lesnar also overeem
steep a jds
nobody beats uh okay
best i've ever seen yeah that's a weird
argument it's what yeah it's all hearsay
yeah it's almost always time what else
you got dude all right this is the
probably biggest
news over the weekend was jake paul
hussein ramon jr fight being canceled
because of weight deception
so uh too many chains right jake but um
yeah so i think here this is so weird so
this is a long one hassam rahman jr so
i'll read it and then i'll give you the
breakdown so uh on july 5th hassan robin
jr so just so you guys know
rahman fights that heavyweight
so when jake was sparring him which was
years ago you know he he was big and
they had issues during the sparring and
then
jake's team didn't want to take this
fight because he's such a bigger fighter
jig goes i got this we'll have him cut
weight and then take the fight so at
least
weight won't be a big huge issue
so we'll take that out of the equation
so he has to make the weight right and
that's why what's that's what hassan
rahman jr agreed to
so
even though he might be more skilled
more experienced
him being a heavyweight isn't great for
jake but what he did do is go okay
that's your advantage we're gonna take
that away you can't
you can't come in over a certain amount
of weight the night of the fight you
can't just blow up to 240 and [ __ ]
knock me out that was his advantage
they agreed to it i'll get
here's here's the article assam roman
junior signed a bout agreement to fight
jake paul in august 6 mass square garden
and a maximum weight of 200 pounds which
is way below even uh cruiserweight it's
below cruiser and it's below heavyweight
right at the time of sign ramen provide
evidence of his weight to give comfort
to most valuable promotions which is
jake paul's promotions most valuable
promotions and the new york state
athletic commission that he would not be
losing more than 10 percent of his
weight over the four weeks leading up to
the fight since uh since weighted at 216
pounds on july 7th
uh rahm and his camp have offered
assurance after assurance pub publicly
and privately that he was on track to
make way at the weigh-in on august 5th
which would be this friday i will be in
baltimore
uh going as far as to provide a letter
signed by recognizing nutrition that his
weight cut was progressing without issue
per new york state athletic commission
required weekly weight checks in the
last 48 hours it has become clear that
these assurances were not made in good
faith on friday this past friday ramen
submit a weight check to the new york
state athletic commission that
demonstrated he had lost less than one
pound since originally starting to take
the fight 24 days prior that prompted
the commission to declare that would not
sanction the fight at less than 205
pounds
still jake paul was prepared to move
forward with the fight the new weight in
the new contract ballsy
uh in the new contract with center rams
promoter reflected to him five pounds
limit imposing strict penalties should
he fail to make even 205 pounds
upon
receiving his new contract saturday
morning ramen's camp indicated for the
very first time that he planned to weigh
215 pounds right which you know 25 pound
weight advantage probably
which is a ton
uh 215 pounds at the official weigh-in
would not agree to weigh in at 205
pounds informing mvp promotions that
they're pulling out of the fight unless
the fight was agreed 215 pounds
yeah i mean
if i'm jake i wouldn't do it either yeah
i wouldn't do it either and also for
ramen god damn you this was your shot i
know this is your one shot and you can't
cut weight you don't have the discipline
and cut weight come on dude the [ __ ]
yeah shame
so that's a bummer
now someone did allude to the fact they
go do you think that this is better for
jake because we know nate is for sure
gonna be out of his contract
does this make it so
um jake can just roll right and fight
nate because let's say jake were to lose
his fight you know possibility
does this just make it just build the
nate fight even more
i mean i see it and does it build the
nate fight what
what happens in a weird world where
nate's a underdog against hamzat what if
nate gets absolutely annihilated does
that affect the pay-per-view by of jake
and also if he gets absolutely
annihilated
and then three months later they
announced nate versus jake what's that
you know does it do anything jake at
this point
even though nate's a legend yeah if he
gets annihilated
that'll be tough but i think no matter
what if he gets annihilated it still
does way better than this card oh yeah
no doubt oh yeah this i've never heard
of this guy until he popped on the thing
what's he say here uh this is excuse
so about two minutes but it's good
let me go ahead and kill all this
internet cat jake paul got going on for
y'all look
um i'm gonna bridge your weight
i campaign that bridge away you know or
otherwise known as heavyweight on
outside of the wbc now look
um i i signed a contract to make 200
pounds within the the three or three and
a half weeks that i had to do it but i
couldn't do it i sent my body why'd you
say something would not let me do it
okay let me get down to 200 pounds
but
where in boxing do y'all see them
cancelling fights a whole week in
advance i didn't even get my last week
to get down as low as i could
um well you know 205.
is penalties involved
keep the purse keep the purse i'll fight
you for the for the 5 000 minimum that's
how that's how much it means to me and
that's how much faith i have in knocking
him out i would have beat this man uh uh
with one hand just like i did again but
let him tell it he already beat my ass
in the gym when i was 2 30. so if you
beat me up while i was 2 30
what's the problem in fighting me while
i'm 215. what's the problem fighting me
in 210 it's it's it's clearly
uh uh
them
not wanting to fight it's not me pulling
out the fight it's them not wanting to
fight i never said that i didn't want
this fight and well no you didn't want
it when you didn't make the weight yeah
you obviously don't want to fight you
didn't make the weight also
to defend jaycare you also agreed a
certain weight limit because that's your
biggest advantage he has no business
fighting heavyweights but he figured
he'd take a shot against you
and then you don't have the discipline
of the professionalism to make the
weight so then jake's team who's
professional going this is already a big
risk for us you're a no-name tough fight
and you're still not going to make
weight no we're out dude
and then i would be willing to bet jake
seems smart they're tracking how how
this is going i i would imagine it
doesn't sell well
yeah that's what so dana white actually
said and also back to uh nate uh and
jake
dana said when he brought jake up to
nate nate was like man that's foolery
that's a goofy i'm not with that goofy
stuff yeah
and i wonder if that's just dana trying
to make sure that that fight doesn't do
well or try to squash it but also
dana said the most the fight that makes
most sense for nate is jake previously
obviously has his issues with jake now
he's saying that nate doesn't want to
take any of that goofy stuff
but then nate has posted several times
about jake yeah
so i'm not buying it i don't know who's
i mean i believe for sure jake and nate
want to fight without a doubt
um
who who's this talking dude it's dana
white talking about it but i would say
this just because you were accountant
here doesn't mean you know what the [ __ ]
goes on here doesn't mean you can run a
fight promotion company i think that
jake paul probably needs to get some
different people around him he's gonna
stay in the sport he needs to be with
guys that really know how to put on
fights
yeah fair because
um
the guy who runs his stuff nikiza uh was
uh ufc's former chief financial officer
agreed just because you're running the
money doesn't mean you know how to
promote a fight
but they're doing something right yeah
yeah he blamed ticket sales
so right here yeah the nate goes on
you'll see ruse now we're giving a fight
with anyone in july alex have a bigger
[ __ ] to do and post a video of jake that
was in june too yeah so they can't be
too
goofy he goes i think they sold under a
million dollars in tickets it costs 500
000 to turn the [ __ ] lights on him at
square garden that's what i think not to
mention a hotel's room in new york
transportation everything else is very
expensive i agree i think this
uh you know i do think jake would have
beat him but i i also think that his
team was like dude
this is a short notice fight no knows
who this guy is he's not making the
weight we're looking at ticket sales
people aren't really excited about this
fight this doesn't do much for your
career i do
you know as far as career-wise do
significantly as far as validation but
is it worth it pros cons there were more
cons and pros like let's just pull the
plug that's why i think happened
for sure
of course dylan danis was like dylan
dance had a hot take on it
what'd y'all say uh if you go to his
twitter he said something like he heard
obviously him and jake have major issues
so take it with a grain of salt but
so jake tweeted first tommy fumbled now
hassan ramen crumbled these boxes are
most difficult people to work with and
continue to lack professionalism and
confidence to fight me i apologize to
all the other fighters on the card our
partners our team fans all right then
dylan put i heard from inside the camp
of jake paul that his manager inside the
camp uh this manager and team tried to
pay hassam ramen to take a dive but they
rejected it so then jake paul's team
made up excuse paul out of the fight
i don't think so that's just dylan being
dylan yeah
all right
but i'm sure some of the internet's
running with that
dylan says some crazy stuff so yeah but
then it's like yeah dylan's right
um so this is dana white saying that
the
shaman's
overwhelming favorite thing is not
necessarily true
he brought up ronda rousey as an example
too
so until we put so is amanda's so is
ronda rousey and go on for days this is
a sport where nobody's that big of a
favorite anybody can win at any given
time one thing that you saw in the
gilbert burns fight let's not forget
about hamzat
as bad as he is explosive of all things
that he's done he doesn't have the
experience all these other people have
do you know why continue nate diaz is
durable he's been in there with
everybody
it's his last fight going out nobody's
that big of a underdog not in ufc nate
diaz says that gangster mentality hamzat
has that gangster people love that [ __ ]
yeah i think i think people love this
fight i think
you know we think we're all an issue
like jesus christ man but i think as
well
um
you know
dana's playing he he's trying to
gain some traction because he got a lot
of [ __ ] for this fight in the sugar shot
fight
you know i don't have a problem with it
okay well i mean when you compared
amanda and ronda rousey yeah
i mean good fight yeah yeah we they they
just didn't know where rhonda's head was
at at the time
all right this is pretty cool kamaruzman
is going to be guest starring in the new
wakanda forever black panther movie it's
big time yeah sequel yeah that's big
time i mean i i don't i'm not into uh
marvel movies uh really but um i know
black panther is [ __ ] massive and
that's big for camaro yes man that's
pretty dope i thought he just doesn't
wear undershirts
i mean he's got the body for it so i
would do it all day yeah this is kurdish
blades talking about jon jones because
john jones was kind of going after him
yeah but uh curtis only said something
like he's a great fighter just doesn't
have that real like one power yeah which
is fair punch not got power and then
yeah john started going out on social
media then uh curtis said i don't
understand why i took such defense to
what i said but i'm over it i don't feel
like i said anything super disrespect
disrespectful or super aggressive we had
a few too many drinks that night i don't
know then he goes on to say this
honestly i won't be angry with the
interim thing if they do jon jones
verstipe at least he gives me a goal
like a trajectory like okay i beat the
winner of two two of us are gone i get
the winner steve jones at least i have
an intern belt and that means i get the
guy who has the real belt that's that'll
be something i can live with that
that sounds about right too right yeah
i'm with that yeah
and the world mma
awards 2022 nominees came out yeah i
don't know if we'll take a look at this
list
uh
fire of the year volkonovsky
ebelin oliveira marchev francis pride
volkowski female fight of the year
that's interesting huh julia pena chris
cyborg kyla harrison
uh chefchanko penting
um god you probably give it to uh pena
right for winning the belt
yeah big ups the one of the biggest
upsets breakthrough friday of the year
uh tuvasa gamrat pimlet mcconn johnny
boone uh i might give it to patio yeah
even international fire of the year
probably hums up
or well book it out
yeah fight of the year i told you how i
feel about yuri vs glover i know it's a
great fight but they both had off nights
gaichi channel is a hell of a fight
boganovsky brianna take it hello fight
uh hamza gilbert burns holloway
rodriguez
uh
[Music]
hi gagey chandler yeah that was pretty
damn dope knockout of the year i mean
chandler ferguson all day
submission um
[Music]
he has just gone just in arm tr arm
triangle trigger was pretty filthy
inverted triangle's always filthy
i give to stevie ray
yeah that was unique
this thought that was weird too come
back come back of the year summer just
this is career are there
fights oh i give sergio pettis all
[ __ ] day that was insane that was
insane dude
upset of the year i mean that's easy yep
that's promotion okay
leading man
leading man referee it's going to be
dana white no matter what yeah referee i
don't know but also
so there's analysts
and then personality our girl laura
single yeah she's nominated yeah i hope
she wins it i think rogan wants that
every year though
that's going to be super tough there's a
few of those where it's really tough to
win yeah
this is shitty news
antonio silva bigfoot scheduled for
another another fight against the
kickboxer that's 102 and 9. i don't even
know how they sanction it it has to be
in i think azerbaijan because they won't
sanction it here
the bomberman
and this is his older manager
this is what he says
says you cannot defend a man from his
own self i did my very best the plan was
for him to stop fighting eight kills ago
he made the money i let go at that point
could not be part of this but he always
goes in with big heart never
uh rely you know his losses jesus christ
he needs to stop yeah and then
this right here
uh and still missing today's boxing kale
and still missing today's uh
so
uh cruz um is saying he's they're not
even including his last boxing ko
someone has to have that conversation
with the man this guy goes you cannot
defend a man yep i just told you guys
yes
you hate to see it is it a money thing
it can't be uh i mean obviously
championship inspirations are over
he has kids man it's tough he's such a
nice guy
yeah yeah i don't know what's going on
with them you kind of explained this
about sean o'malley but he has no one
that manages him so he doesn't want any
middleman he wants to handle everything
himself
which
is
say you see his sponsorship dealing
whoever handles that you see they're
like the ufc wants sugar shawn
i'm going to this management and their
management takes 20 50 whatever just
tell tell me about the deal
not to do anything just say hey the ufc
called you want this deal sure it's same
thing with the fight money too you want
50 of my money because you did what no
that ain't happening oh he wants some of
the bonus too that ain't happening um he
says i personally enjoyed uh doing all
the business side of things good for him
there are some fighters who are probably
like [ __ ] up i don't want to look at
that stuff you take care of it and i'll
give you a percentage
there's people like that cool i like
being part of my deal i like uh to be
directly communication with all the
brand deals ufc specifically
everyone i don't want any
miscommunications
that always seems to happen when there's
an extra voice in the middle it's just
not necessary at least for me yeah as
long as it works for him he's killing it
i think he could get dicey when he
say say beats peter yawn
and let's say you were to be the winner
of al joe and tj when you're champ
that's a little dicey you know because
if you have big man listen i'm all about
not going with big management but if you
have big management they can at least go
hey we have this current champ he's
getting this you deserve this because
then you don't know your value you know
but i'm sure you could find out sugar's
smart dude
you know yeah when you were doing it
with the was lex the guy that handle
everything yeah how much of
what you said actually went into the
deals or did you just let him out of it
yeah i mean when i was fighting out i i
only i cared about controlling my merch
and then i always had self
worth as far as like when they wanted to
negotiate deals like too low i'd rather
just not do it i'm not gonna sell myself
for that but
um
yeah it's not like they would call lex
mike right here's you know brendan wants
crow cop or whatever it's not like
you'll be like okay let's work on it
do you see what's called hey you're
fighting this guy it's not like my
manager's like negotiating
and you're signing the deal you know
it's tough but also a lot of guys don't
have a business background so it's like
to negotiate your contract [ __ ] you
don't know like
you know you ask what you think is fair
but you should probably ask for more
because you know they're gonna not take
the first offer like there's all there's
etiquette there you know so a lot of you
guys it's a lot man it's a lot sure
a rare breed man you know
all right a quick fight announcement
edson barbosa versus this up and coming
badass ilya yeah
this is ilia's record
he's killing it yeah i'm doing barboza
and that's barboza
yeah
yes very tough fight for him
all right i assume he will be the
underdog he's won three out of his last
like 30.
all right so that iranian hulk guy on
instagram that photoshops his body all
the time i know who he is okay
he actually got into a boxing fight and
got destroyed because remember he backed
out of one because he was saying mental
health yeah but
and he got pushed so far back the
easiest oh wow
here we go
they're fighting with shirts on these
boys a big big
straight left hand got through already
already
oh my god
looks good he's really bad
oh he act like that hurt
oh my gaze oh this guy is just awful at
fighting away he's turning away yeah
fighting if he turns away one more time
the fight's going to be stopped
[Applause]
because i'm tight he's terrible
do you know what that other guy would
have done to him that's why he was like
i'm out remember we got pushed yeah and
his mom was like uh they want to disown
this yeah yeah my family's gonna disown
me
well what do they think of this
yeah jesus christ he's bad yep iranian
hulk my ass
uh do you remember uh vanessa democolos
she's the one that jumped on joe rogan
she used to be a show yeah yeah so she
did this little wrestling thing
sumo wrestling thing i'll just show you
i'll play it for you
[Music]
this is like actual sumo oh yeah
so watch
oh sick
did he just toss her like that
but she played alongside that boy's
thick yeah sumo dude
and um oh this is just an update from
brian
ryan t city chin up chest up i got this
and think i got this and thank you all
for the mad love although i can reply to
all the messages i read them keep them
going my final doctor means tomorrow you
guys know soon all right hope he's okay
man that surgery would be a [ __ ]
tough man yeah so you'll know soon
eyes man
this is an ex-usc fighter that fought in
rising and he just knocked his opponent
out and also did a soccer kick and i'll
show you the replay here
yeah that was i thought was going to be
way more vicious but it wasn't that bad
uh this is disgusting so this
georgie sent this over
i'll just play it for you
[Music]
he's kind of like he's going for a
boogie chalk on the op
oh that's kind of like he's going for a
boy my god
and then the head is clear
he's out looking for the knee right now
he's like my arm dude
what do you know the buggy choke was he
doing it correctly i don't know what
though
that makes me feel sick yeah it does
um
this as well
[Music]
look at that
look at that they're gonna let it go and
they're looking awesome i love it i love
it look at that oh my god
so that was our ufc fight pass on your
uriah faber's
league
jesus christ a1 combat 4 but then you
want to be a fighter huh the referee did
not allow him to yeah so that was it
where are we doing
kids making 800 bucks yeah and that's
pretty much it dude so that's it just
yeah that's it quick one today doggie
you got a ufc uh
fight night this saturday the main event
co-main event are fantastic the rest of
it you get the ultimate fighter
heavyweight tournament uh finale on
their ultimate fighter 30 women's
flyweight tournament i don't know who
the [ __ ] watching ultimate fight these
days but you know god bless those guys
um you know it's low when they're not
even the co in main event you know like
even when i was
fighting when i was the ultimate fighter
we at least the main event the co-main
event was jon jones matt hamill
that's how far that's dropped but um
yeah the let me see the cartoon yeah go
back to the card for me
uh yeah so you got thiago santos jamal
hill man jamal hill is on a freaking
banshee path uh you know jamal hill is a
savage i think jamal hill takes this one
um santos started off hot he said
following some tough times
we'll see where he's at mentally but
i'll take jamal hill man be a knockout
he's a savage i think uh santos
technique is better but i just jamal
hill just has it yeah he's myself
vicente luke uh neil our boy from texas
roadhouse texas roadhouse love the uh
i love the bread there
the bread at the steakhouse yeah they
had good bread steaks all right but yeah
no i actually love their food uh i don't
know if they're out in california but uh
this is kind of a
fork in the road for both gentlemen luke
a who's coming off the loss to muhammad
and then uh neil who beat muhammad uh
you know forking rough for both of them
to stay in the queue at welterweight and
then you get the the main events of the
kind of the finale of the ultimate
fighter but you know
decent card yeah main co-main for sure
and that's all real quick uh anthony
pettis is gonna do a rematch with stevie
ray that's this friday oh dope yeah pfo
good for him uh-huh hopefully he figures
out at pfl it's been a tough road for
him though
it's been like it won like one i think
it's been tough road uh swinging a tough
road i leave at 6 a.m on thursday to
baltimore baltimore this thursday friday
saturday never been to baltimore
come get some baltimore this freaking
thursday friday saturday club is
magooby's out there i've never been
named the club's interesting uh it's
magooby's in baltimore maryland this
thursday friday saturday and then one
night one show only at a theater in
chicago downtown chicago den theater
chicago august 26th that's coming up man
so august 26th is the den theater in
chicago downtown the next day on 27th is
the tough mudder in chicago right
outside chicago sign for the thick
mudder at 10 a.m it's me versus the
buttery bros use the promo code team
brendan you get 10 off the entire signup
uh fee there so it's limited capacity so
if you're gonna wait don't wait things
gonna sell out they're not gonna have
any more um they should put more tickets
for sale because they're selling so fast
so i'm telling you man there's gonna be
no more so if you wanna run with the
thick boy squad sign up for the thick
mudder august 27th go to toughmudder.com
that's in chicago that's at 10 a.m heat
you'll see it on there thick mudder all
right
so chicago's 26 though at the den
theater appleton wisconsin never been
there september 8th through the 10th
ontario ontario improv california
september 15th to 17th great club uh and
then another first time i used to do the
wilbur mixing up this time boston
uh laugh boston not doing the wilbur
your boy's doing a club laugh boston is
september 29th through the october 1st
in boston one of my favorite cities my
son is named after boston so
one of my all-time favorite cities
that's september 29th through the first
laugh boston uh but baltimore you are up
this week baby come get some this
thursday through saturday magooby's
baltimore maryland august 4th through
the 6th tickets at
fatkz.com
um think boy merch dropped you get the
white tees you see me wearing tank tops
we have the new blue tie day as well and
tie-dye shorts and the new trucker hats
so get you some at thickboy.com
tie-dye donut collection uh we got the
trucker hat the classic hat and the
white tees and tanks so get you some all
right kids be nice to each other like
subscribe thanks for following we'll
have some big news for you guys coming
up in regards to fight companions in
august it's gonna be a fun one we love
you guys thank you so much for watching
like subscribe and that's it
be safe